so 12 years ago I was at the Venice
biennalev architecture I always go to
the Singaporean Pavilion because usually
I find friends there and of course you
know piachu was there and so I I met
with you too but then also I was really
riveted by the insulation that year it
was called 1000 singapores and in talked
it talked about the fact that the world
could all fit in a thousand singapores
of the size if just you just express the
same density and like responded to
certain conditions and so I remained in
touch with Eric lero and Belinda Huang
at gupembang who had curated that
Pavilion and it's it also turns out that
pen bang and Belinda are The Architects
for Pinnacle then when I came here to
Singapore I had a taste of what real
density and livable density feels like
so tonight when I was deciding with Mark
and uh and with narelle how to close the
Symposium and it's symposium design
Futures we decided to ask Eric Belinda
and pembang to talk about a thousand
Singapore's 12 years later so I would
like to call on stage Eric lauro first
and then Belinda pembank to tell us what
happened in 12 years Eric lauro
[Applause]
a good evening on behalf of Belinda
pinkbing and Florian Schatz who could
not be with us tonight were delighted to
be the conversation closing the design
future Symposium as part of Singapore
design week thank you to design
Singapore and a special thanks to Apollo
as the curatorial Director who has made
this event such a thought-provoking
afternoon and evening it's a little bit
odd for me as an American speaking of
Singapore yet I believe my 20 years
living on this small little island on
the equator gives me a relatively
Solid Ground from which to reflect my
friend and colleague kuping Bing who is
an almost authentic Singaporean but a
Malaysian actually and Belinda who gives
the Singaporean gravitas to round out
our Cosmopolitan diversity Paula asked
us to reflect on an exhibition we did as
she mentioned for the Venice biennale in
2010 titled 1000 Singapore is a model of
the compact City the exhibition was a
thought provocation and a challenge to
consider the ways in which we occupy our
planet or as Buckminster Fuller called
it spaceship earth
in 2010 Singapore's planning parameter
was to grow to 6.5 million
times a thousand we got 6.5 billion the
population of the globe some 12 years
ago using the area of Singapore times a
thousand the entire world's population
could be housed in only 0.5 percent of
the earth's land area
let that sink in for a minute it was an
absurd but shocking statistic and it
provoked a significant amount of
discussion on what is the right density
to live
where and how does a city like Singapore
feed itself sustain itself and what are
the right models of governance and
community structure to produce a
thriving Metropolis
by asking such questions and looking
inward what was evident that Singapore
is and was a laboratory a petri dish of
ideas where the urban world might be
heading
but today Singapore hasn't reached six
and a half million and the world is now
8 billion by using today's numbers we
would need about 1400 singapores to
house the population and about 0.7
percent of the earth's land area
the numbers have changed but only
slightly the premise holds that a
compact dense Urban system has a very
small footprint if applied across the
planet
we explored and explained the unique
Singapore model in 2010 by cutting a
slice from east to west
shipping the slice of Singapore to
Venice
creating a very analog exhibition tube
of white ventilation blocks that form
the architecture which should have been
in mailing's mycelium bricks
a long linear model of the Singapore
slice was complemented with a thousand
photographs and diagrams that explained
on the particularities of the Singapore
model
with no special technology or gimmicks
the exhibition put on the display of the
laboratory of Singapore as it is
where the scalar relationships between
part to whole abstraction to realism
hardware and software people and
architecture were made visible
ending with a Singapore red seat in
front of the Venice Canal a perfect
space to reflect on the modes of
urbanization and our Collective design
future
the photographs and diagrams were
organized from world to unit or unit to
world with an end piece on the future
diagrams of world density GDP automobile
ownership power consumption and other
metrics between large nations were
compared and contrasted to Singapore
through drawings and photographs
that spelled out the unique Singapore
model at the national scale
interjected with photographs by Gene
quack humorously commenting that yes we
too can have fun and be ironic in
Singapore
where townships were examined and
described across the physical
infrastructure and soft amenities
embedded Within
contrasted with local Street culture
with a structure of neighborhoods were
examined and described in architectural
form
with Clues to the tremendous effort to
produce those Landscapes with a foreign
worker construction force that literally
and metaphorically does the heavy
lifting
where each Precinct of the Singapore
slice was drawn and contrasted as a
collection of parts
while making visible the manner in which
our jungle context is cleaned and
trimmed by a top-notch army of
manicurists
Singapore's tremendous Housing
Development board system which is in
many ways the Envy of the world was
drawn and modeled to explain it to a
global audience
while positioning those diagrams next to
foreign domestic labor that cares cleans
and confronts young to elderly alike in
his bustling Metropolis
where Flats units and Architectural
types that compose the hdb ecosystem
were placed in comparison
and set adjacent to the lovely aunties
and uncles who call this world home
while we looked inward to understand the
Singapore model we also imagined the
sizes of China the USA and India at the
respective densities of Singapore
compressing each country into one giant
City
where the entire world would be housed
in one Texas or two Italy's if only they
followed the Singapore model
at the same time we started to look at
the problems of Singapore and its larger
footprint Beyond its borders its carbon
dependency its dependency on fuel food
and agricultural resources and how much
land was required to sustain the
lifestyle that we enjoy I'm getting the
shock now yeah realizing that almost
half
insula Malaysia was required just to
feed us
what was clear in 2010 and elaborated on
in the first session and actually many
of the themes in the Symposium today is
that Singapore is a laboratory of the
future a petri dish where Singapore's
size model of governance and a
commitment to continually build the
nation through hard and soft instruments
have led it to where it is now
back in 2008 writers were describing the
uniquely Singapore model as an
indication of where the urban world
might be heading
a model that seemingly offered lessons
to those looking in from afar
it was a lesson of compact complete and
connected Urban environments where
liberal economic forces are managed with
expert governmental care
where density and diversity sit side by
side
looking back from today what is now
clear is that a tremendous number of
blind spots were not addressed
or or even in our field of view
from the climate catastrophe that we are
all witnessing on an almost daily
experience to the very real concerns of
social environmental and
intergenerational Justice to embodied
carbon decarbonization ESG and Planet
positive X we're doing good and
eliminating the need to consume half of
Malaysia for our lifestyle have become
front and center of any discussion on
urbanization even here in Singapore
where happiness care love and the deeper
values of what it means to live on this
little red dot are now taking a more
Central stage and suggesting a different
course of where our design Futures might
be heading
the exhibition never intended to have
all of the answers
nor proposed Singapore as the answer but
rather to open the conversation around
forms of urbanization to learn from and
to ask even more questions
I'm going to invite my co-curators
[Applause]
well um
Thomas and Irwin said that they were the
dessert so we are the Grappa for tonight
[Laughter]
so back in 2010 we were already uh
looking at hyper density and the
Pinnacle duxton at that time was really
the idea for the Pinnacle duxton was
planted by Lee Kuan Yew himself who was
xionguan's boss and he continued to be
radical in in his 80s you know so this
is proposed to be three times the
density of a typical new town so all
that you saw just now but multiply by
three
um and of course we were concerned with
the lack of sociability the massiveness
of the building the communal spaces and
the highly contested ground we thought
that this would be really challenging
how could you make this livable
um so we covered the car park with a new
ground and we created new grounds in the
sky that became really peaceful places
and mediated the two most challenging
um programs which is a public park
versus a private home
um
and the sky Gardens we created about one
hectare of new communal spaces in the
sky and that at that time these types of
spaces were pretty new and everyone was
so afraid that you know this might be I
don't know there I call it places that
you might want to end it all but
um
so we designed these parks to be
Palace in Wonderland was
um was the inspiration and you can see
down there the little beach I think
Paula was up there and sometimes after
after the rain we we created a pond that
kids would swim in but the Town Council
didn't like this kind of spaces so we
had to talk and discuss but since then
lots of Sky Gardens have blossomed up
across Singapore and
you know we're just gonna
share this super density with you if
every one of you on planet Earth were to
live in a building like vinegar duxton
we could just use a tiny building and uh
it could just be on top of the MRT line
and we could house the entire population
Singapore more than that the entire
world can shift into Metropolitan New
York and the palace neighbor
[Laughter]
30 000 square kilometers there more than
enough
so this is really
you know testing our imagination about
footprint and how much we use of the
Earth or how little we choose to use
so since the 1000 Singapore's many
models of Sky Gardens are seen today
today you also saw
um Dawson at skyville um by Mansa and
um there were also a lot of
experimentations on biophilic buildings
so here you see
um another project of ours which is the
temples it's a private condominium and
um you know up up to up to this all the
sky Gardens that we did were single
floors clear communal spaces but here we
wanted to experiment
um having units itself come out and be
connected to the sky Gardens itself I
mean it's very similar to The Village
and and having that landed property feel
and and again I think it just takes um
it takes Visionary developers and
clients to really understand and willing
to try this and so basically we just
have a very thickened volume around the
the typical of condominium block and
what we found was that
um that really helped in enabling this
you know the the idea that when you walk
past and see life you are going to
adjust yourself right in in the
environment rather than be living in
your own unit doing your own thing
um it's nice to be able to just Meander
past her neighbors itself increase the
um sociability and also the community
building
so also on on this on this facade right
was the idea of bringing green a lot
closer to the units the high-rise units
also we had these six Story vines and
that were growing up um through the
entire
um spanning between the sky Terraces
itself so that so that the units from
within could also be experiencing
um um that green environment
and the barracks uh you know we took
Thomas's advice and not tear down all
our buildings and we kept this and we
turned something that was built uh for
hostility to something of hospitality or
here at the department of architecture
at nus a few miles
um from where we're sitting this evening
the 1970s institutional building has
been adaptively reused into a Net Zero
Energy complex as an example of
decarbonization that extends the
original carbon inheritance from a
previous generation from the 1970s and
we're using it for the education of
singaporeans today and tomorrow here the
jungle thrives as the heart of
architectural education in Singapore
uh were biophilia and The Dramatics of
climate become the protagonists within
the architectural student community
um and where delightful spaces allow
students to study and learn within an
ecosystem where doing good and
environmental justice takes center stage
in the context of our climate
catastrophe so with another minute to go
in 30 slikes
go through it really quick I think
um
what what is the future what's beyond
1000 Singapore and I I really connect
with what you were saying Thomas because
at the end of the day the heart of it is
um the heart and the emotions and and
and when you talk about education last
year I actually had a design studio in
nus and it was called emotional
architecture unfortunately I think um I
needed to take two weeks to to counsel
the students to really start to feel but
you know workshops like this that you
see we've done two weeks ago when we
actually engage students and and the
young ones are so full of life but at
the same time you will also have 15 year
olds that just simply talk about
um not having any meaning where you can
just simply places where you can just
simply take your own life and that's the
truth of it and
um ping-ping students in the University
yeah we just I just asked them to draw
what they felt about the new towns that
they were visiting around outside and
they started to draw pictures like that
um so on the left hand side
um it was a machine that he felt like he
was chasing after a foe and in return he
found himself being chased and he was
going round and round without an exit
eventually uh ending up in a
narcissistic cage of control uh so so
this is this is what this is what our
young they're really feeling about this
face if you talk about education and you
talk about emotion you really had to
start
from from the really young and this is
again the the a project that we Sorry a
workshop that we just did just taking a
green open space just in the First new
town of Singapore and just creating
um a space where young and old and the
public could come in and there was
connection there was happiness there was
joy and um
um I I think we were just really quite
uh happy to see how it moved um every
single person that participated in this
watch I think we just want to share with
you a future project that we have been
working on this is going to come alive
in 2030 and maybe become mature in 2050.
uh just give us a minute to just sort of
just share I'm just gonna skip to this
uh part here
um I just wanted to say that right at
the heart of this project
um is well-being and happiness because
what's the meaning of a city where
people come together and you run very
fast and very hard but you're driven by
fear and anxiety so what songwon was
talking about was something that got us
here but where do we want to go from
here it has to be based on well-being
and if we were to design a city that
cares about well-being the definition of
Love is a willingness
care for the well-being of another and
the other you could expand into
biodiversity into everything and the
idea of holonic nesting is extremely
important because we shift from a
mechanistic logic
to a biologic where one system nests
into the other in larger and smaller
scales each one complete and whole so we
look for wholeness in every step
including the handrail detail that
Thomas is looking at so we can plan a
city from the smaller scale
as an agent and an agent-based data that
drives the entire system one nesting in
another driven by 12 principles of
well-being
and this 12 principles of well-being
okay I'm just going to close here so
thank you
that links with the planet the people
the emotions and backed by the science
of Happiness thank you so much thank you
and um Mark you want to come on board
thank you I'm sorry to cut you short but
I want to be able to ask you with the
little time that we have left the big
question which you started answering
with the whole on you know and with the
happy lab okay yeah perfect so let's see
how much time backstage gives us because
there are a seven minutes okay we all
have the seven minutes
architect I mean Thomas learned he had
to go through Ted where they made him
rehearse 1500 times he was good also
before no but um the question is the
issues that were not addressed in 2010
those issues that Eric listed and that
you started saying you took into account
with happy Labs so I remember a few of
them
Wellness certainly helps you know having
people in the center and then the slides
they didn't showed also layerings and
all these different strategies that can
be adopted to obviate to some of those
issues but what has remained with you of
a thousand singapores and if you were to
do it today would you do the same
exhibition I mean now it would be 14 000
right
because I remember you showed us the
difference but what would you do
different what what's changed
I I don't know for me we have started to
do the technical stuff really well like
we started count energy and low energy
systems and all of that and putting in
all the matrices so all the technical
stuff we can do very well but the
emotional stuff the stuff that uh Thomas
has mentioned we actually started doing
that with those photographs to try to
inject a sense of irony that even as we
are building something there could be
something else that we were creating
that could be a problem and we already
had a sense of it because uh the
machines that we wanted to build As
Cities just were not meant to respond to
human beings and but we still needed
them because we only had a very short
time to house so many people to raise
them do all sorts of economic stuff but
I think if we were to do it differently
um if we were to do it today we had 400
more pictures to put in yeah no I can
imagine that I can imagine that and
actually that picture of the whole alone
was really important because it showed
the interconnectedness I mean in the
morning and no I keep on thinking we
also we're here in the morning it's not
it was only an afternoon but Aaron was
talking about Quantum and the
entanglement and the idea of being
modular and systemic at the same time so
it's very important to see that that's
the different uh the different Paradigm
so I didn't announce him properly but I
wanted Mark we the director of the
design festival and also my partner in
crime in this organizing the Symposium I
wanted him to be on stage because we
realized when we were talking with
Belinda and Eric and ping bang bang that
I'm the outsider and he's The Insider
and we had really interesting questions
so now I would like to give you the word
and for you to ask your question no I
mean it was just I think there's clearly
a common common train of uh inquiry
right I think Thomas he spoke about kind
of emotion and you guys were sort of you
know really kind of jumping into that as
well and I guess maybe as a Singaporean
trying to understand what is kind of you
feel so urgent what do you think that
are the sort of emotions you think we
need to be designing for in our
communities and you kind of alluded to
that with a happy lab but maybe it's a
good time to sort of unpack that
um actually if I could speak into it
it's just beyond emotions I think uh
Professor Lim actually spoke about how
when Lee Kuan Yew started there were if
you listen to him there were a lot of
values in that trustworthiness
um discipline and actually what we want
to hold on to is actually to continue
this trajectory of Virtues and and you
mentioned what would
um what would we put in in the if we did
the exhibition it would be the human
development it'll be the intangibles
it'll be where we are and if you look at
or you listen to what Professor Lynn say
um whatever you saw in in oh I'll slice
even probably but the way we we
presented it as well right it's about a
city of efficiency it was a necessity it
was for survival we're talking about the
lower two physiological need levels that
that that Maslow talks about in this
hierarchy of human needs but but now if
we are going to move into the next era
then we have to look at our
psychological needs to the the sense of
belonging
um talking about love talking about
esteem meaning and purpose and Trust
because you know that's something that
also Mark brought up the other day when
we were talking I have seen few
societies with such high level of trust
and
um and I feel that I'm very glad that
Belinda that you brought up values
because that was a big discussion you
know the the expression of values
through design is something that we have
heard over and over and over today and
uh and it should really be reflected in
everybody's work I would like to bring
up if you don't mind now a question from
the audience that is kind of sweet
said so a thousand singapores has been
my favorite biennale concept what are
the main reasons that put off the world
the rest of the world from adopting our
high density living models what's their
problem oh well maybe you can answer
them from New York no I mean I have many
answers and I think that Thomas has them
too uh but um I don't know maybe maybe
Eric since you are like it's kind of
like double agent well I think I mean
you know the exhibition was always meant
to be a provocation that's the first
thing it wasn't meant to be really
applicable the world over it nor should
it ever be the applicable the world over
it's and I think that's the beauty of
Singapore is that
um people whether it's designers or it's
policy makers or governmental officials
um people from around the world can come
and look at Singapore and kind of take
what they want right or learn from what
they want it's not really meant to be
this kind of exportable model that can
be applied to any place or geography or
culture so the reason why it's not being
adopted everywhere is because every you
know location has its own particular
cultural Arrangement social Arrangement
governmental Arrangement
um so the problems have been adopted
anywhere
I mean I I think there's a lot of
lessons that are are you know that are
um that Singapore represents that are
transformed and translated
um to both areas in Southeast Asia I
think areas in Asia in general
um I'm not an expert in this um I'm sure
there's some policy um and government
people here in the audience who would be
able to you know pinpoint that more
accurately but I mean clearly the fact
that
so many people in the audience are here
with us today and I know there's a lot
of people internationally that are here
with us speak of the kind of interest
and curiosity around the kind of magic
sauce that makes up Singapore but can I
offer a perspective
um first um he needed a long-term
planning policy and it needed
um the social the economics so we had
the EDB and we had the hdb and everyone
is like working together as system so
you couldn't have housing affordable
housing without the calculation as to
what is affordability and what what size
and understanding of culture so all of
these was what we showed all of this in
the 1000 Singapore's about the numbers
about how we were precisely calibrating
everything land prices and there was
this system that's going on everywhere
so it's not just the physical thing
what's going on behind needs also to be
put out you know so that people can
learn and I think going forward we may
not need to adopt this kind of
mechanistic boom boom boom sort of you
know the the modernist replication you
know maybe we can think of new and
better ways to do 1000 Singapore's you
know that sounds good and I wanted to
ask you because we've run out of time
also
um is there a place where our audience
can go and see happy lab the project
that I sadistically cut from your
presentation
you can come for a forum on Friday on
Friday at the urban Redevelopment
Authority you sign up for it you can
find it in ptix under Aki Forum because
you know that's what's also happening
right now there's the whole archifest
going on so it's like a mess of not only
design but also architecture so yeah I
want to say something Mark no I just
thought I'd also put a plug uh not for
myself but uh I know the the Ura
recently just finished a long-term
planning review exhibition and that was
first time they really kind of engage
the public extensively about how we want
to live together and I think when I went
through the exhibition and it's also
online is I found a lot of these sort of
softwares like cherish like sustainable
like these kind of things that obviously
people want
in our living environment and I and I'm
starting to think of Thomas when you
talk about how maybe a science comes in
we can start to actually scientifically
understand and identify emotion and in a
way planned and design for emotion and
successful emotion in the building so
I'm just gonna curious to understand
that in the future maybe it's scientists
working with Architects to really be
able to project emotion into the design
that people are thinking about now don't
ask it as a question put up an
exclamation mark otherwise narelle is
gonna kill me because we have to yeah
that's what that's how it's going to be
the future
integrating integrating that's how it's
going to be but seriously I I want to
thank you for being such good sports
also with my constrictions of time and
for giving us an update on what
evidently is a beloved project by many
in Singapore and outside so thank you
very much thank you thank you thank you
thank you well
you know what we've come to the end and
uh just a few remarks I mean supposedly
I should wrap up by making kind of a a
conclusion and bringing together all the
threads of today but I think it's too
tall of an order and I think you should
look at your notes I should look at our
notes and my notes and then we should
get together but I think it was for me
at least a successful Symposium because
as usual hardly any question was truly
answered but many questions that's how
it goes but many questions were
formulated better you know what I'm
saying I think that's that's already
incredibly successful we've been talking
about density we've been talking about
values we've been talking about what it
means to work together when civil
servants and the citizens really work
together and citizens are citizens
scientists are citizen Architects
citizen designers so the idea of really
designing together and working together
and living together and living for one
another and then as Michaela and I would
add also for others species so I think
that the main goals of the day were to
demonstrate this closeness of people
that design policy and people that
design buildings and objects maybe they
didn't know how close they were and
hopefully they'll know more about it
today one two demonstrate the systemic
nature of our life and how tackling that
kind of complexity can help us and how
design can give us the tools to tackle
that complexity too number three the
need to think long term and not just a
palm in front of our nose as we would
say in Italy right and number four to
really think about care you know so many
people talk about the care industry that
kind of gets on my nerves it's about
just care as a value care for other
people of all ages and really for the
planet also so I think that kind of sums
up what we talked about today and
Singapore gave us the trampoline to talk
about it because it's such an
interesting and unique unique place for
experimentation and for design so I
would really like to thank all of our
speakers they've been fantastic so
please give them a hand it's been great
and then I would like to thank our
organizers the design Singapore Council
of course and then Su today design Z and
the EDB
and then I want to work I want to thank
the people that I worked with very
closely from the design Singapore team
so Mark we woohoo
hey
modeling home yay
thank you
Serene back
Hermann Putra
Janine Liu
Grace so
and then especially especially and I
would love it if you came here for a
second no come on okay all right if you
want if you want to end the Symposium
with me I would be honored it's Judea
Chung and narel yabuka
thank you so much
Oh no you're being so great and I would
like you can sit so you're more
comfortable and then we would like to
really all together we would like to
thank our event production company which
is the mice Studio our graphic designers
practice theory I have a matching person
yet
the events archery for the ticketing and
then of course the team here at Victoria
Theater this amazing venue
um there's a survey of course so we
would like to know what you thought of
the Symposium yeah uh it would be
greatly beneficial if you could fill out
a survey to help the organizer or to
optimize the second the next chapter
yeah yeah keep me keeping a job so
please scan the QR code to provide your
feedback which would mean a lot to us
also for those of you who need CPD
points and for members of SIA Sila and
s-i-d-a-c-c Doc don't forget to claim to
claim your county continuing
professional development points in the
atrium please head to the information
counter to do so
um Singapore design week 2022 runs until
September 25th and there's still lots to
do it's true from the fine day Design
Fair Asia and the emerge Showcase of
Southeast Asian design to PDA tours
special exhibitions and events from many
design Community Partners and more so
please participate architecture design
at all different scales and levels and
with that I really want to thank you for
joining us at Agency for the future and
helping us Build a Better World for all
and I wish you good night
thank you
okay before we end Paula
we have a special gift for you
thank you so much I think
I think we can all agree that Paula did
an amazing job uh curating and putting
together an entire Narrative of agency
for the future and design for our
inaugural design future Symposium so we
just want to say thank you Paula for all
of this
thank you Don